with no further delay let's get into
hatred mail here is what hatred mail is
because it's time to make America hate
again Patriot mail written by Patriots
who hate David Pakman because America
and because freedom so some hatred males
are particularly vile or aggressive or
whatever this one is just really oddly
specific in terms of the ideas that it
proposes take a listen to this for all
those Pakman fans who don't know yet
when you pay for the premium membership
you get a pair of fudge pac-man's undies
as a bonus as your most devoted hate fan
I should also get a free membership to
the fudge Pakman show this will
demonstrate in the typical Lib [ __ ]
capitulating fashion just how devoted
you liberals fats and queers are to
bending over and taking it up the
tailpipe from your enemies practise what
you preach fudge practice what you
preach it's actually easy for fudge
Pakman to get 500,000 subscribers on
YouTube you just have to go full Lib
[ __ ] like the young turds or Jon Stewart
so obviously this is insane the one
interesting thing in it is the mention
of the 500,000 YouTube subscribers Pat
and I just the other day we're running
the numbers and we calculated that based
on the YouTube subscription rate in 2017
so far if it stays steady we would be by
the end of the year at about five
hundred and twenty thousand YouTube
subscribers but that's assuming it
doesn't change at all for the rest of
the year but funny that the hatred also
was keyed in on 500,000 subscribers he
was also doing the math himself got an
idea that if you sign up for membership
you get a copy of your underwear I'm
yeah that's not so true you just get my
socks
what's a copy of underwear anyway it's
not actual underwear it's just like oh
it's a replica it's a replica I was
imagining like you go to a Xerox machine
and it's just literally what you would
get by hitting the copy button if you
put underwear on the piece of glass
anyway you can turn hatred mail into
something positive
you won't get a copy of my underwear but
you will get a membership at 40% off if
you use the coupon code hate reott 40